Donald Trump and his attorneys were
sanctioned a million dollars one million
dollars the attorneys had a bad week in
fact they had the mother of all bad
weeks when a federal judge fined them
and their client 938 thousand dollars on
top of sixty six thousand dollars in
Prior fines blasting them for filing an
endless barrage of garbage lawsuits as
part of quote A continuing pattern of
misuse of the courts which quote
undermines the rule of law basically
they filed some bad filings and found
out and along the way the court called
them out for being really crappy lawyers
lamenting that our current laws are
incapable of handling people who are
just bad at their jobs now generally
that's not something that you come back
from that's something that sends you to
an ashram for a month for silent
contemplation to think about where it
all went wrong and how you can ever face
the world again or it would if you were
a normal lawyer but like their client
Donald Trump's attorneys are immune from
shame and that's a pretty handy skill
you know what Alina you're not going to
win you can't win so how did we get here
well in March of 2022 Donald Trump sued
Hillary Clinton the Clinton campaign the
Democratic National Committee former FBI
director James Comey and two dozen other
parties from the Kraken Cinematic
Universe we kept adding defendants you
couldn't stop adding defendants Trump
demanded 72 million dollars in Damages
to his reputation and legal fees that he
incurred during the Mueller
investigation of his campaign's ties to
Russia Trump was represented in this
case by his now regular attorney Alina
Haba who went from general counsel from
a parking garage company to an attack
dog for the former president in just a
few short years we have to fight she was
joined by Peter ticton a Florida
insurance lawyer whose claim to fame is
that he was Trump's roommate 60 years
ago in a junior Military Academy where
he helped Trump secure the quote Ladies
Man yearbook award the day after the
suit was filed Haba went on Sean Hannity
Show promising to avenge Trump for the
great Injustice of the Mueller
investigation a crime allegedly
perpetrated by Hillary Clinton and the
DNC you are going to make up lies if you
are going to try and take him down he's
going to fight you back she followed up
with a news max hit where she promised
to that by suing Hillary Clinton Trump
was defending democracy itself but what
the real goal is is democracy Now put a
pin in those interviews because we'll
come back to those later now according
to rule eight of the federal rules of
civil procedure a complaint should
consist of quote a short and plain
statement of the claim showing that the
pleader is entitled to relief basically
you tell the court what happened what
laws were broken and what you want the
court to do about that um this complaint
was not that instead Trump's lawyer
spent 108 pages screaming that Hillary
Clinton and the vast network of
democratic operatives engaged in quote
an unthinkable plot one that shocks the
conscience and is of an affront to this
nation's democracy the defendants
responded in April with motions to
dismiss pointing out the many many
problems with that particular complaint
this put Trump and his lawyers on notice
that their case was hopelessly defective
or in layman's turns hot garbage but
instead of fixing it the 85 pages of
ranting and several other even crazier
legal theories U.S District Judge Donald
Middlebrooks was not impressed saying
quote to say that plaintiff's 193 page
819 paragraph amended complaint is
excessive in length would be putting
things mild wildly the theory was that
Clinton maliciously conspired with the
Deep State FBI including supposed
Clinton loyalist James Comey to Gin up
the FBI's Crossfire hurricane
investigation into the Trump campaign's
Russia ties which is quite the leap
considering the Comey never revealed the
ongoing FBI investigation of the Trump
campaign but did make public comments
about the Clinton email inquiry in late
October which some people think cost her
the 2016 election that Trump also blamed
Clinton and her minions for the Mueller
investigation even though Trump's Deputy
attorney general Rod Rosenstein was the
one who appointed special counsel Robert
Mueller and yes Trump sued Rosenstein
along with everyone else accusing him of
participating in a scheme quote so
outrageous subversive and incendiary
that even the events of Watergate pale
in comparison so the complaint was long
on hyper-caffeinated rhetoric and
disastrously short on law it also played
pretty fast and loose with the facts
themselves but most clearly it implied
that the FBI's Rush investigation was
the result of a scheme quilt conceived
coordinated and carried out by top-level
officials at the Clinton campaign and
the DNC including the candidate herself
who attended to Shield her involvement
behind a wall of third parties the
pleading cited the Justice Department's
inspector General's report which
absolutely said nothing of the kind in
fact the report found that the inquiry
was opened after a low-level Trump
campaign operative named George
Papadopoulos the infamous coffee boy got
drunk and blabbed to an Australian
Diplomat that Russian operatives were
going to start releasing hacked
materials to harm the Clinton Campaign
which they did strategically dumping
stolen emails from the campaign and the
DNC using Wikileaks as frontman now
instead the complaint suggested that
Trump came under the investigation after
a democratic attorney named Michael
Sussman tipped off the FBI about
suspicious internet traffic between the
server in Trump Tower and a sanctioned
Russian Bank Russia if you're listening
I hope you're able to find the 30 000
emails that are missing in reality the
crossfire hurricane investigation was
opened in July of 2016. months before
Sussman showed up at the FBI in
September and among other things Trump
also blamed Hillary Clinton for getting
him kicked off of Twitter in January of
2021 but the factual problems with his
complaint paled him comparison to the
Myriad legal deficiencies in his order
dismissing the case judge Middlebrooks
highlighted the quote Audacity Of
plaintiff's legal theories and the
manner in which they clearly contravene
binding case law which is Judge speak
for this complaint is not just hot
garbage but basically judicial Nepal now
first the suit was filed in Florida
where none of the defendants reside you
can't just Sue anyone in any Court the
parties have to have some connection to
the place where the cases heard to
establish what's called personal
jurisdiction Trump's lawyers made the
novel argument that the defendants quote
knew that Florida is a state in the
United States
which was an important one and thus I
guess could be hauled into court in the
Sunshine State because they knew it was
a state I I don't know now second the
statute of limitations for all the
conduct allegedly had already passed by
the time that Trump and his lawyers got
around to filing this complaint and as
the defendants pointed out in their
motion to dismiss Trump's supposed
injuries took place in 2016 and 2017 and
thanks to his constant tweeting he was
well aware of them at the time quote
notwithstanding his rousing all-caps
call to action plaintiff waited four
years four months and 24 days before
filing suit and that made him way too
late to file but mostly the suit failed
because Trump's claims were
nuts he alleged that Clinton and her
goons violated the racketeer influenced
and corrupt organizations act in a
conspiracy to derail his political
Ambitions yes they claimed it was Rico
and of course it's never ever Rico
cool
but okay let's pretend for a minute that
we're living in some alternate universe
where it could be Rico a world Trump
would dearly love to be in since it
means triple damages for the plaintiff
Trump would have to point to a specific
criminal action known as a predicate to
establish the conspiracy Trump's
predicate was the theft of Trade Secrets
his theory was that the DNS lookup data
which Democratic lawyer Michael Sussman
reported to the FBI was proprietary
information stolen from the Trump
organization except that DNS data is
public information that can't be stolen
because it's not secret much less a
trade secret and without the RICO the
whole lawsuit fell apart pretty quickly
not that it wasn't already there was no
predicate for any of the tortious
conduct allege or tortuous as Trump's
lawyers wrote it 10 times in both their
first and second complaints Trump's
lawyers also managed to embarrass
themselves in a variety of creative ways
for instance they repeatedly described
defendant Charles Dolan Jr as a resident
of New York even after Dolan sent them
in affidavit saying that he lived in
Virginia when called out on the air they
insisted that they'd done their due
diligence as lawyers because there are
lots of people named Dolan living in the
state of New York and if you're a lawyer
who finds yourself having to make this
argument you've probably already lost in
an attempt to get their case in front of
trump appointed judge Eileen Cannon his
lawyers first filed the case in Fort
Pierce Florida you might recall the
judge Cannon later went on to do a whole
bunch of favors for Trump when the FBI
seized a massive cache of classified
documents at his home at Mar-A-Lago all
to have that undone by three
conservative judges on the 11th circuit
but the Gambit to get the Ricoh suit in
front of her failed and they wound up in
front of Judge Middlebrooks Who was
appointed to the bench in 1997 by Bill
Clinton instead of taking their lumps
they filed an ill-conceived motion to
get him to disqualify himself for they
described his quote Prejudice so
virulent or pervasive as to constitute
bias against the party judge
middlebrook's declined to recuse himself
having had no contact with anyone named
Clinton in 20 years and it didn't get
better from there with Trump's lawyers
drafting a rebuke from the court for
putting the home addresses of public
figures like Comey and Rosenstein on the
public docket so many times it appeared
to be not an accident and in April the
defense filed motions to dismiss the
case this required each of the dozens of
people that Trump said were in on the
RICO to hire lawyers in Florida to read
this wild complaint research the claims
draft a pleading explaining why the case
was nonsense and generally litigate the
case now that was a tremendously
expensive undertaking and in June after
Trump filed an amended complaint that
was even crazier than the first one they
had to do it all over again but unlike
Donald Trump who can raise money from
his supporters to pay his lawyers the
defendants were each on the hook
personally for tens if not hundreds of
thousands of dollars for legal fees even
though they went on to win the case
that's the general rule in the United
States even if you win you still have to
pay your own attorneys but in September
judge Middlebrooks issued a blistering
opinion dismissing Trump's Rico lawsuit
he wrote at its core the problem with
plaintiff's amended complaint is that
plaintiff is not attempting to seek
redress for any legal harm instead he is
seeking to flaunt a 200-page political
Manifesto outline his grievances against
those that have opposed him and this
court is not the appropriate Forum
noting that Trump's lawyers had been
disingenuous about the conclusions of
the Justice Department's report on the
origins of the Russia investigation he
remarked quote plaintiff and his lawyers
are of course free to reject the
conclusions of the Inspector General but
they cannot misrepresent it in a
pleading and the court found that the
statute of limitations had already
expired on Trump's Rico claim but quote
even if plaintiff's Rico claims were
timely they still fail on the merits at
every step of the analysis judge
Middlebrooks ended his dismissal order
with the ominous Line quote I reserved
jurisdiction to adjudicate issues
pertaining to sanctions which as judge
speak for please file emotion asking for
sanctions Trump's lawyer Elena Haba
reacted to this missile in her usual
fashion she ran to Fox News to whine
about all the unfairness of it all now
is it wise to go on National Television
to talk smack about the judge presiding
over your case in word no but that
didn't stop Haba from complaining to
Sean Hannity that it was a quote sad day
and she was trying hard not to lose
faith in the justice system not only do
we get dismissed he says that this this
is not the proper place for recourse for
Donald Trump he has no legal
ramifications well what is the proper
place for him now admitting on National
Television that you brought the case
against the express wishes of your own
client is
well that's that's definitely a choice
the former president looked at me and
and he told me you know what Alina
you're not going to win you can't win
just get rid of it don't do the case and
I said no we have to fight it's not
right what happened uh particularly when
you know that the court has all but
invited the people you dragged down to
Florida for a junk lawsuit to file a
sanctions motion against you and it
didn't take long for Dolan the guy who
really lived in Virginia to request
sanctions against Trump and his lawyers
now not only had the plaintiff screwed
up his address but they'd also falsely
claimed that he was quote a former
chairman of the DNC and an active
participant in a criminal conspiracy
Dolan argued quote large and small
matters are falsely and cavalierly
presented in plaintiff's pleadings any
one of these false statements is grounds
for sanction adding his resume is quote
available online and could have been
easily checked now Dolan sought
sanctions under rule 11 of the federal
rules of civil procedure to get rule 11
sanctions you have to send what's known
as a rule 11 Safe Harbor letter two
opposing counsel saying essentially your
case is tear terrible I'm putting you on
notice that I intend to ask the court to
penalize you for filing it and the
recipient then has 21 days to withdraw
the complaint without penalty and no
matter how outlandish the filing you can
still walk away without getting
sanctioned but that's not what Donald
Trump or his lawyers did the rule is
meant to deter junk lawsuits by
punishing parties who file pleadings
with no reasonable basis based on a
legal theory that has no reasonable
chance of success or which are filed in
bad faith for an improper purpose judge
Middlebrooks found the quote here all
three are true tearing into Trump as
lawyers for their quote deliberate use
of the judicial system to pursue a
political agenda he described the
complaint as quote political grievances
masquerading as legal claims and warned
that quote the rule of law is undermined
by the toxic combination of political
fundraising with legal fees paid by
political action committees Reckless and
factually untrue statements by lawyers
at rallies and in the media and efforts
to advance a political narrative through
lawsuits without a factual basis or any
cognizable legal Theory the judge fined
Trump's lawyers fifty thousand dollars
and made them personally responsible for
another sixteen thousand dollars of
Dolan's fees and costs he also suggested
that the attorneys should face
discipline from their local bar
associations for abuse of the legal
system now with dozens of other
defendants signaling their intent to
seek normal sanctions against Trump and
his legal team judge middlebrook's order
was a flashing red warning light that
something very bad was about to happen
and just a few days ago judge
Middlebrooks dropped a hammer ordering
Trump and his lawyers to Fork over
another
938 thousand dollars in legal fees to
the defendants he dragged down to
Florida for this pointless exercise and
it was clear from the first sentence the
judge Middlebrooks was absolutely
Furious quote this case should never
have been brought its inadequacy as a
legal claim was evident from the start
no reasonable lawyer would have filed it
he excoriated Trump and his attorneys
for recklessly advancing claims which
quote the most basic legal research
would have revealed were nonsense he
went on to say it was not that the
complaint in amended complaint were
inadequate in any respect they were
inadequate in nearly every respect and
he accused Trump's lawyers of
misrepresenting and cherry-picking
public documents quote to support a
false factual narrative in a quote
deliberate attempt to harass the
defendants noting that quote it happened
too often to be accidental now having a
federal judge accuse a lawyer of filing
a complaint which was quote completely
frivolous both factually and legally in
which was brought in bad faith for an
improper purpose is humiliating and one
lawyer tweeted quote I just turned in my
bar card ain't no way I could recover
but judge Middlebrooks went even further
calling out Trump and his lawyers for a
quote continuing pattern of misuse of
the courts and noting that this lawsuit
quote did not come close to stating a
legal claim because that was never its
intended purpose now according to judge
Middlebrooks the intended purpose of
this lawsuit was to use the federal
court as a political fundraising tool
Trump never expected to win and didn't
care he filed it so he could continue to
raise money and scream about the
so-called Russia hoax and the same goes
for his other frivolous lawsuits against
the Pulitzer Prize board CNN Twitter and
the New York attorney general the court
described a litigation Playbook
consisting of quote provocative and
boastful rhetoric political narratives
from Maga rallies and attacks on
political opponents and the news media
Trump showed a disregard for legal
principles and precedent while attacking
the courts as biased when he doesn't get
his way and most important he raises a
mountain of cash off the lawsuits and
Pays His lawyers with money donated to
his political action committees AKA Pax
now Pacs are fundraising vehicles for
political candidates which are
theoretically separate from the campaign
and largely exempt from campaign Finance
regulation but the court noted that
Trump's save America Pac paid 9.7
million dollars in legal fees for Trump
and his allies since 2021. with two
million dollars going to haba's firm and
Haba recently became a senior advisor to
Mr Trump's new Maga Inc Super PAC so the
whole system feeds on itself Trump files
a frivolous lawsuit sending out emails
to a supporters begging for money to
fund it the lawyers head to Friendly
media Outlets to Hype up the case which
leads to more money being donated which
is then used to pay the lawyers who file
even more frivolous lawsuits and on and
on and on it's like a virtuous cycle
except without the virtue part and the
legal system isn't really set up to
handle this and as judge Middlebrooks
angrily points out in his order that's
not what the courts are for it's
unethical for Trump's lawyers to use the
federal docket to host political
fundraisers and it's an abuse by Trump
himself whom the judge describes is
quote a prolific and sophisticated
litigant who is repeatedly using the
courts to seek revenge on political
adversaries and The Mastermind of
strategic abuse of the judicial process
our current libel laws are a sham
and a disgrace so the court made Trump
and his lawyer Lena Haba jointly liable
for the millions of dollars and
attorneys fees accrued by the defendants
in this case and that means that the
defendants can seek the sanctions from
any one of the particular parties and
then once they have recovered then the
offending plaintiffs can work out
amongst themselves how they're going to
contribute to each other and you can bet
at least in the future that every single
person sued by Trump is going to flag
this order for the presiding judge is
proof that Trump is a vexatious litigant
notorious for filing frivolous lawsuits
but in the meantime Trump's attorneys
from the Florida law firm of Weber crab
and wine appear to have gotten the
message loud and clear they represented
the former president in a bizarre
lawsuit filed in Florida state court
against the New York attorney general
Leticia James Trump had hoped to get a
Florida judge to intervene in the New
York state civil suit against him in his
company but the case was removed from
Florida State Court to Federal Court
where it landed on the desk of you're
not going to believe this judge
Middlebrooks just hours after the judge
sanctioned Trump and Elena Haba the
Weber crab firm filed papers to Vol
voluntarily dismiss the suit against the
New York AG they did not however
withdraw Trump's defamation lawsuit in
Okeechobee County against the 19 members
of the Pulitzer Prize board but you know
baby steps so maybe now Trump's lawyers
will stay home for a little while and
maybe instead of lawyering badly they
should try learning a more ascertainable
skill like cooking delicious home-cooked
meals which they could do with today's
sponsor hellofresh hellofresh is a great
way to eat delicious fresh food while
still being healthy it's a great way to
get back into a diet or just eat great
food in fact hellofresh has a whole
variety of calorie smart carb smart
pescetarian and veggie options and you
can customize it however you like
hellofresh delivers fresh quality
produce from the farm to your door in
less than a week so you can enjoy
favorites like Falafel power bowls
seared steak and potatoes with Brunei
sauce or Southwest pork and bean
burritos now I'm a do-it-yourself person
and I have to say I was initially pretty
skeptical about hellofresh I'm a pretty
good cook so I didn't think that I
needed the help but I actually loved it
even for an experienced cook hellofresh
delivers new ingredients and recipes
that I'd never try on my own hellofresh
generally keeps everyone's face favorite
meals and then rotates in new ones all
the time in fact I usually increase the
size of my hellofresh servings so I can
enjoy leftovers for lunches as well and
of course everything was delivered
straight to my door so I didn't have to
do any shopping the produce actually
gets to you faster than a grocery store
so it arrives at Peak freshness and
flavor and it's also super easy to save
time hellofresh cuts out meal planning
and prep so the recipes only take 20 to
30 minutes to cook literally less time
to cook than it would normally take to
do the shopping and it's also incredibly
sustainable since the ingredients are
pre-portioned there's less prep and less
wasted food and the packaging is almost
entirely made from recyclable or already
recycled content and hellofresh's carbon
footprint is actually 25 lower than that
of meals made from store-bought
groceries and of course 72 percent
cheaper than dining at your average
restaurant so if you'd like to try
hellofresh go to hellofresh.com and use
the code legal eagle 65 for 60 off plus
free shipping yes you can actually get
65 off plus free shipping by click on
the link that's on screen or down in the
description so go to hellofresh.com and
use the code legal eagle 65 or just
click on the link below plus click on
that link really helps out this channel
and after that click on this playlist
over here for more legal eagle or I'll
see you in court